.
I have sent an interesting question of algebra
I think the question is not well formulated, or maybe it is
Some information is missing
But it is an interesting question though, so
I think I will solve it. We can talk about why
Which makes its wording unclassified
If you give us a pairing (f (x
It is considered to be the third-degree polynomial of the formula
ax ^ 3 + bx ^ 2 + cx + d
And give us a set of zeros for this polynomial
And that we have zeros on point 1.0- and
Point 2.0
The intersection of y, y intersection
Located on point 0, -2
What is required of us is, what is the output of a + b + c + d?
Suppose that if we can progress in this
The first thing we can think about is, how
It looks like a third-degree polynomial and what we mean
When talking about zeros
Let me draw a diagram
I do not know exactly what form appears to be a third-degree polynomial
It is still
Let me paint the axis
Now the third-degree polynomial can contain three zeros
Drainage is the points where
Equals 0
If we have 0 on point 1.0-
This point is located here
We have 0 on point 2.0
1, 2, 0
These are the saffron given to us
I also give us that the intersection y falls on point 0, -2
Intersect with y axis here
But it can contain three zeros
Now some of them can be compounded
But the composite zeros come in pairs
No married couple
I do not want to go into details now
If this must be zero real third, because if it is the third zero
Composite, you will need to zero another composite, and
You can not get a fourth zero in the third-degree polynomial
Since its third root, it can be used somewhere
Here, maybe here
Or it can be bis for one of these two
The two roots here
But let's assume that we have a third root
We do not know how it looks
Let 's suppose it looks - suppose
The third root is located somewhere here
Then its representation is possible, and I can be completely wrong
I suppose, but until we get the meaning
For the form of a third - degree polynomial, how can we represent a graphic that intersects with
X axis three times, the possible graphic representation will appear
So
Curves, infect another zero, afflicting y axis
Then come back
Maybe he'll go that way, maybe he'll go the other way, so
Up then down
Well, there are several ways you can paint something out
Bend twice to intersect with these three points
And y that cross also, but I will not order
These are all now
But let's see if we can find transactions here
If the key point here is it
There must be a third zero
Let me name it with the third zero, and it is located on the point, located on
The point - let's call it - r3,0
Use r to denote roots
The roots are x values ​​for the expanse
If we say that f (-1) = 0, we will say that x
= -1 is a root
Similarly, we know that f (2) = 0
Or we can say that x = 2 is a root, these are two roots
When someone tells you about 0, it is also
It tells you about the root, then we know it must be
Third root on point x = r3
If x = r3
Now, if we have a third-degree polynomial where these three x values
Make it 0, we can rewrite the third-degree polynomial
So - we can rewrite it - I'll do it
In a different color - f (x) = x + 1--
You'll see why you put x + 1 instead of x - 1 in
Second - + 1 x x - 2 x x - r3
We will put a abroad, and I will inform you
Quickly because of my condition for a abroad
Because if we want to multiply the words x only, when
We distribute and multiply
For these polynomials, you'll get x ^ 3, but we have
ax ^ 3
If we need it here for a constant until we turn it into a
Now, why did you write it this way?
Well, if you put -1 here what will happen?
This statement will become -1 + 1
Which equals 0
What will take care of this or what a
Something will be 0
If we put x = 2, this phrase
Here will become 0
Who will take care of the other phrase or to a
(f) 2 will equal 0
Similarly, when x = r3, this last statement is 0, from
He will take care of anything here
We know that this can be rewritten
In this format
If we can find r3 we can multiply this
We try to make a matching pattern to find
These transactions
Now, the key to the other solution given to us is the intersection y
That point, ie 0, -2
Tell us that f (0) = -2
Well, how much is equal to f (0?
(f) 0 - I will write here - (f) 0 - if you put 0 here
This statement will become 0, this statement will become 0, and that phrase will become 0
And we have d
If f (0) = d
Or we can say that d should equal -2
d = -2, so at least we found one
Of effective communication
The fixed term is d = -2
Now, if d = -2, it means all these
Fixed phrases, when you hit them with this
The phrase, plus a, is because a measure
Everything, it should equal -2
Let me be clear here
Let me rewrite this phrase
That's worth it, I'll hit a this
With the last phrase
We can use any order we want, if this is equivalent to x
+ 1 x x - 2 x ax - r, please let me know
Type
This is equivalent to this thing at the top, will
Type it using f (x), and this
Equivalent to the above
Now, in order to find R3, or try to find R3
You should realize that when we multiply this
The way to get a static statement here, or d
Here, this will be a product
For the fixed phrase in our phrases
Because if any products are inserted by adding any of the x statements
Here you will get one of these other phrases
The phrase ax ^ 3 is generalized from that phrase, that phrase
That phrase, mingled with each other
Then the fixed phrase multiplied
So that we can strike them together
Then the 2 in the middle multiplied
With different components of fixed phrases
You'll see that if we want to
We hit it
But if you follow me in this way, that is, to strike this with this
Actually let me write this way
So, so that = d
Then we can find a relationship between a and d
Which equals -2
So we can say that 1 × -2 × -3, these two
The two references are deleted
= Terms d
Which equals -2, so if we spread it
A little bit we'll get 2ar3 = -2, divide both ends
On 2a we get r3 = -1 / a
If we do not find the third root, we get it
In terms of coefficient a
But let's see if we can use it in a useful way
If r3 = -1 / a, how often does this phrase become?
Let me rewrite it
Well, I'll write it in blue
f (x) = x + 1 x x - 2 x ax
- Now a × r3-
Let me write it here
a × r3 = -1 / a-
That negative signal × negative signal
It is a positive signal
The a
We get 1
If this is the case now, if we replace r3 with this
It becomes a, will become a + 1
a × -1 / a- = positive 1
Positive 1
We replaced it instead to get this
Now let's hit this
Let us carry out the forced beating
We see what we will get
I will strike these two words first
I will use a different color for that
Let me hit these two phrases here
This is equal to x ^ 2 + 1x
- 2x, this is an -x, is not it?
1 x x = x, -2 x x = x - 2x
Ie -x, then -2, multiply
These two boundary variables
Then I would have to hit it with Ax + 1
I will write ax + 1 down here
So keep the space
ax + 1
Now I will do some forced beatings
1 x -2 = - I will do this purple - -2
1 x-x = x-
1 x x ^ 2 = x ^ 2
Now ax × -2 = -2ax
2ax-
ax × -x = -ax ^ 2
ax ^ 2- then ax × x ^ 2
= ax ^ 3
ax ^ 3
Then we collect everything, and we get f (x)
= ax ^ 3 - Let me go to
Left slightly - ax ^ 3
x ^ 2 - ax ^ 2
This is equal to 1 - a, 1 - ax ^ 2
Then we have these two groups, so they become
-1 - 2a, or we can say = - -1
- 2a-- or we can say -1 + 2ax then
2, and this is logical because that is what d equals
That is d
That is the solution already
This is how the equation will be
The reason I said at the beginning of the matter is that
The equation or issue was not well defined is that
I can choose any real number for this equation
These conditions will be met by us
I suppose he did not give me all the restrictions
This issue
Perhaps there is a third restriction is a =
1, b = something else, or a + b
= Something else
But using these limitations, use these
Limitations, the formula will take this shape
If this is the case, of course this is a, and this is b
Which is 1 - a, that is b, and that is a, then
This is equal to c
You can choose, as you know, we can choose
One option is specific if we want to get an answer to the issue, but it is
Perhaps it will not be the expected answer to it
Maybe a different was chosen
But if you choose a simple value like a = 1, then
How much will b?
b will be 1 - a, equal to 0
Ie that b = 0, then that c = - in fact that c
That negative sign would include - c would be 1 + 2a
2a = 2, 1 + 2 = 3
We put a negative signal
If c is equal to -3
Of course it does not matter what to do, where d
Will equal -2
If we choose a = 1, the answer here to a question is a result of a
b + c + d +, will be + 1 -3
1 + -3 = -2
-2 - 2 = -4
That is another possibility, but we can easily
We choose it, you know that a can be something, it can be
Break, can be anything
Could be, you know a can be -1
A can be equal to -1, and if it is a = -1, then the b
= 2, hence b = 2, is not it?
Then that c = 1 - 2, ie -1, but
We have a negative signal abroad
Then that c = 1, then that d is always
Will equal -2
d = -2
Then we have a + b + c + d =
Well, these two are deleted, and they become 0
We do not know exactly what the answer is
The author of the matter is looking for it, but it is an interesting issue
As you know, out of curiosity - let us take this
The first example we took - as a = 1
Thus we can look at how root must be
If it is a = 1, therefore the third root is r3
For this case here - r3
It will equal 1/1 which equals
-1, which means that we will have a duplicate root
We will have a duplicate root here
We do not need a distinctive root here
If we are curious to see how it looks, let's
Look at the case where a = 1
In fact maybe we'll look at both
When a = 1, the equation is x ^ 3
- button x - x ^ 3, none
The expression x ^ 2, - 3x - 3x, - 3x, - 2
Let's take them together
This is where we chose this option
For laboratories
Then let's deal with this option for transactions, if we have, if
We had x ^ 3-, right? a = -1 + 2x ^ 2
Then we have, + x - c = 1 - then + x - 2
So that's what we've discussed
Let's see how they look
Let us represent them graphically
If first, let's start, we've got that point
That is the double root
Note that both of these graphs are done
Restraints
Both have a root on -1
Both have a y-junction on y = -2
Both have a root on x =
Positive 2
Now the second, has a distinct and separate third root
While the first, here, possess a double root
Here
Anyway, I think the issue was
Some enjoyable thing was where we had to look
Different solutions
In fact, we have an infinite number of solutions
Its based on the value of a which we choose